To be a part of something like this is something you would never be able to recreate...
...once you're done playing the game.
And I'm blessed to be a part of something like this.
I know we've seen the championship board already out there and the yellow tape...
...and that's why you play the game to the final buzzer.
James catches, puts up a three!
Won't go, rebound Bosh, back out to Allen, his three-pointer. Bang!
Tie game with five seconds remaining!
It's back-to-back titles for the Heat, the 2013 NBA Champions yet resides once again in Miami.
Parker the other way, the spin, and he puts it through.
Tony Parker!
Look at the speed of Leonard!
He drops it in high.
Oh my goodness.
James on the attack to the rim and a foul!
Here's Chalmers gives it up, Ray Allen will take a three for the lead.
It's in!
Ray Allen!